- You've made so many great
shows and movies in your career.
So many that we've enjoyed so much.
And I watched your-
- Well, likewise.
- Oh, thank you.
Well, I watched your
new show, "Severance."
- Oh, cool.
- I mean-
(audience applauding)
- What'd you think?
- It's so...
First of all, it's
directed by Ben Stiller.
I'm loving watching it.
Tell us about it.
- Oh, thank you.
I'm so glad you like it.
Yeah, and you know Ben, you
know what a brilliant guy he is
and he had this vision,
and Dan Erickson, who
created the show as well,
but Ben kind of took it and came up
with a whole visual
language for this world.
It really was world building,
cuz there's this whole science fiction,
and so you have to introduce the audience
to all these circumstances
and this whole world
of this company and this technology.
The show takes place in a world
where you can have a chip
inserted in your brain,
so when you go to work,
you take an elevator down to the office
and on that elevator ride,
the chip is triggered,
so when you're down there,
you have no idea who you
are in the outside world,
you have no access to those memories.
Your entire life and
world is there at work.
And then when you leave
work at the end of the day,
it's triggered again and
you're in the outside world,
but have no memory of what
you did at work that day.
So you have these
two separate lives.
- How wild is that?
(audience applauding)
I mean.
- Yeah, it's really
cool. It's a cool idea.
It's really fun.
- I was... I really...
I knew that going in and
it didn't ruin it for me.
It helped it and I loved it and I think,
"What an incredible premise
for life, a show, a debate?"
It's so rich, really.
(upbeat music)